graduates of the class of 2020 family
members and friends it's a privilege to
be able to speak with you even in this
unusual way I know you would rather be
on campus and I wish you could be here
but I'm glad we can all do our part to
reduce the transmission of kovin 19 and
stay healthy over the past several
months the novel coronavirus has spread
around the globe infecting millions and
claiming far too many lives it has come
to nearly every community it has come
here to yells doorstep this crisis has
been a wake-up call for all of us it has
stretched healthcare systems to the
breaking point
it has threatened economies both
household and global unlike many
tragedies it is exposed the vast gulf
between the most fortunate and the most
vulnerable long after the pandemic
itself has subsided we will need to
commit ourselves to finding new and
creative solutions to these long-term
problems it may be too early to say what
we have learned from all of this but at
the least we see more sharply than
before our interdependence as a human
community our deep levels of connection
and need for one another are a weakness
that infectious diseases exploit but our
interdependence is also a source of
strength and vitality in uncertain times
indeed all of the time many of us has
found inspiration in the sacrifices of
frontline hospital and health care
workers in the commitment of essential
staff and in the contributions of public
health experts and legions of volunteers
all around us we have seen ordinary
people transformed into heroes what does
it mean to be called to
heroism to step out of your normal life
and do something extraordinary how do we
know if we will respond to such a call
perhaps the most famous story of this
kind is the parable of the Good
Samaritan you are probably familiar with
it
a man is travelling along a road when he
has attacked by robbers who leave him
for dead
three men pass by the first two poor men
of high standing ignore the injured man
the third man a Samaritan a social
outcast stops to help he tends that a
dying man's wounds puts him on his own
donkey and takes him to an inn where he
pays for his stay he even tells the
innkeeper he will come back and pay for
anything else the man needs the
Samaritan is a true neighbor to the
dying man and he is the unexpected hero
of the parable one of the classic
studies from my field of social
psychology takes the Good Samaritan as
its jumping-off point in the 1970s to
psychologists conducted an experiment to
understand why people help or don't they
chose a group of seminary students who
are studying to be ministers the
students were told they needed to go to
a nearby building to prepare sermons on
what else the parable of the Good
Samaritan then they were divided into
three groups the first group was told
they had plenty of time before they
needed to be at the other building the
second group was told they needed to
hurry or they'd be late and the third
group was told they were already late
and really needed to hurry so we have
all these different students on their
way to work on their sermons presumably
with a good Samaritan on their minds but
as they're walking between buildings
each encounters
one needing help actors of course but
pretending to be very ill or hurt in
some cases the actor was lying on the
sidewalk and the seminary students had
to physically step over him to get by
the researchers wanted to know who would
stop to help well not many
although two-thirds of the people who
thought they were early stopped to help
fewer than half of those who were told
they were just on time
did so worst of all only 10% of the
seminary students who thought they were
late took the time to check on the hurt
person that means that 90% of those
students thought it was more important
to rush to work on their sermons about
the Good Samaritan that to take care of
someone who is sick or hurt and alone
maybe this was the real lesson of the
parable as the researchers pointed out
perhaps the first two men were not bad
people they just had busier schedules so
how busy are we are we too busy to be
neighbors if nothing else that much has
changed in the past few months faced
with a global pandemic of staggering
scope we have had to slow down we have
adjusted our lives and our expectations
and I believe we've seen a bit more
clearly but it's meaningful and
essential perhaps too we have seen our
neighbors but in some ways we face an
even greater challenge now than the one
the Good Samaritan or the seminary
students faced they couldn't help but
see their neighbors they were right on
their path but in trying to contain the
spread of Kovan 19 we've had to act with
concern for people we don't know and may
never see
we've had to think about neighbors who
are very real but also very abstract we
have been forced to reimagine who and
where our neighbors are when this crisis
is over this is the lesson I hope we
carry with us that we must act with
urgent concern and compassion for the
neighbors we know personally and those
we do not for people down the street and
for those on the other side of the globe
for Kovan 19 is not the only pandemic we
will face it's not the only challenge
you will tackle yes there will be other
infectious diseases other public health
challenges but I'm thinking too of
different kinds of pandemics right now
our neighbors around the world are
already experiencing the deadly effects
of climate change they are living
through extreme weather events and
rising sea levels scientists tell us
with confidence that these conditions
will only get worse unless we take
drastic action to slow the warming of
our planet the lives we save tomorrow
depend on our actions today what else
threatens the health and well-being of
the human family what about the pandemic
of poverty the illness of inequality
will react in time or ignore the problem
these are questions we must answer
together our interdependence can be a
source of strength but only if we agree
to look beyond our immediate line of
sight only if we learn how to see our
neighbors today I can say with
confidence that the world is full of
neighbors and heroes
I think of Chaney Kalinin a 2019
graduate of Yale College who has joined
others in our community to volunteer
with the New Haven Medical Reserve Corps
Chaney is working with some of the
city's most vulnerable residents while
completing her master's degree at the
School of Public Health where she is
helping develop a program to track over
nineteen in the state I think of a group
of current Yale college students who
started a company to connect senior
citizens with phones tablets and other
devices so they can keep up with their
doctors appointments via telemedicine
these students are working with
volunteers across the country and they
recently delivered a shipment of devices
to patients at the West Haven VA Medical
Center across this city and region
countless individuals are staring us
through this crisis health care and
other essential workers are risking
their own health and well-being to care
for others scientists are working long
hours to understand the disease first
responders members of the National Guard
and volunteers are distributing foods to
those in need on this campus a
remarkable staff and faculty members
have made so many changes and sacrifices
to ensure the best outcomes for our
students and this community and you
members of the class of 2020 and the
midst of unprecedented circumstances you
have demonstrated concern for your
neighbors near and far you have made
great personal sacrifices to protect
others you've given up big moments
recitals performances and championship
games who have missed in-person classes
and year-end rituals and you've also
missed quieter moments meals and
conversations walks with friends
Old Campus and down Chapel Street yet in
the face of disappointment and hardship
who have remained committed to your
studies you have continued to invent
imagine and create who have stayed
connected with friends and family
members you have rejected isolation in
favor of community you have strengthened
the ties that bind us together as a
university and as a human family and
today I encourage you to think of the
Good Samaritan
in a new light not how great or amazing
he was but how ordinary he was life
calls each of us how everage human
beings - acts of extraordinary courage
these are no ordinary times the world
needs each of you prepared to tackle
whatever challenges come your way
I am confident with eyes open and hearts
full of compassion you will take yells
mission of light and truth - neighbors
near and far members of the class of
2020 on behalf of the entire Yale
community faculty students staff and
alumni we salute your accomplishments we
are proud of your achievements remember
to give thanks for all that has brought
you to this day and go forth with
grateful hearts and helpful hands ready
to lead and serve a world that needs
your talents gifts and caring spirit now
more than ever
congratulations class of 2020